Getting naked is usually great .. But not
this time
What’s up guys I’m Sapna here for DNews.
In the movie Everest that came out in 2015..
kind of a spoiler alert but not really and
the movie is based on a true story... but
anyway… so towards the end of the movie
.. one of the guys who was stuck at the top
of Mount Everest overnight in the bitter cold
starts to rip off his coat and outer layers.
That might seem super weird but it’s actually
a documented phenomenon unofficially called
paradoxical undressing.
The reason it’s called “paradoxical undressing”
is because stripping down while you’re freezing
to death is the exact opposite of what we
should instinctively do to protect ourselves
from the cold!
But it happens to some people during extreme
stages of hypothermia.
Hypothermia is when the body temperature dips
to dangerously low levels-- below 95 degrees
Fahrenheit
A study by German researchers in the International
Journal of Legal Medicine looked at 69 cases
of death caused by hypothermia.
They found that 25% of those victims were
partially or completely naked.
And an article in New Scientist suggests that
20 to 50% of people who die from hypothermia
may exhibit signs of this bizarre behavior.
A study in Sweden looked at 33 cases of people
who fit the description based on police reports..
And they found it was pretty much even across
the board in terms of men and women and age
range.
During the later stages of hypothermia…
people are really out of it.
They’re disoriented.
If they were drinking or doing drugs, that
of course may factor into the confused behavior
and bad judgement.
But beyond that … there is another reason
why extremely hypothermic people may take
off all their clothes.
They do it because they actually feel hot.
There are a couple of physiological theories
behind this.
According to a study published back in 1979
in the Journal of Forensic Science... one
possible explanation for paradoxical undressing
is peripheral vasoconstriction.
Peripheral vasoconstriction refers to tight
constricted blood vessels in the outer parts
of the body...like the arms and the legs.
That’s a good thing in extreme cold because
it keeps blood flowing inward to the core
organs.
But the theory is that when the body becomes
so exhausted from fighting the cold.. the
tiny muscles that keep peripheral blood vessels
constricted tire out.
So the blood vessels open up..
The blood rushes back to the skin.. and creates
a really hot flushed feeling.
Another theory is that extreme cold messes
with the brain-- the hypothalamus region in
particular, which is the central command for
body temperature regulation.
If the cold causes the hypothalamus to malfunction…
it may alter signals to the body.. making
you think you’re really hot when you’re
not.
So taking off clothing may seem like a great
idea... even though it’s not.
There’s one more part to this wacky phenomenon
that I want to tell you.
Just before freezing to death.. humans also
tend to burrow or wedge themselves into a
tight space.
Some call it terminal burrowing behavior.
That German study we talked about earlier
discovered that the hypothermic people who
were found partially or completely naked were
also found in a tight space..
Like underneath a bed, behind a wardrobe or
on a shelf.
A tight space can help minimize heat loss
so unlike getting undressed, this burrowing
behavior actually makes sense.
It’s not fully understood but those German
researchers say it’s thought to be triggered
by the brain stem..as a protective measure..
Kind of like how warm-blooded hibernating
animals burrow into a small, enclosed den
for the winter.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
Long before you get to extreme hypothermia,
frostbite is concern.
… Trace explains what frostbite really does
to your body in this video
What other bizarre human behaviors do you
want to know more about?
Tell us down in the comments and don’t forget
to like and subscribe for more DNews every
day.